- Doing good for other
people is a good strategy.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Beautiful Day" by
Davon ft Eric Wortham II)
I would say this is
my current POV because
I think it's actually important
that I have a different answer
for this at 50 and 60 because
you can adjust to the reality.
I'll give you a good example.
If something terrible happens in
my life and it's disease based
or it's because some kid was
texting while he was driving and
hit my dad those will become
things that I want to leave a
legacy about 'cause that's
just how we act
as humans, right?
They become your truths.
But, no question,
this will never go away.
I want to do the following,
I'm fascinated by the same thing
that attracts so many
of millions of people
to people that
are selling bullshit,
those same people
are attracted to me.
And what I want to do is
suffocate out all those other
people and become the alpha of
that entire world of people that
are hoping and are desperate
to look at me and
what I want to do
is inspire two 14-year-old girls
in Kansas City right now to
build a billion-dollar company
on having a bunch of employees
hugging each other in the halls.
I want to build the biggest
building in town ever by just
building the biggest building in
town while I think most people
try to tear down
everybody else's building.
So I think positivity and good
is practical advice to building
an empire and I want to be the
poster child of the person that
built the biggest baddest
empire and did it by being
a good dude along the way.
We're trying to help our leaders
become better businesspeople
'cause I believe in them.
Lindsay, right, you get to
work with at Vayner Talent,
she knows what she's doing
and she runs a tight P&amp;L but
then I'm always
trying to break it.
It's a matrix for them, right?
'Cause when they sit
with Alan at Chief Financial,
they're trying to run a business
but then I'll come over the top
and be like, "No. This is
working to hire more
"and you're gonna have a
negative P&amp;L this year."
But they're like, "But Alan,"
I'm like, "Fucking
Alan works for me."
It's a whole thing.
It's a whole thing but it's
been great 'cause we're back to
pushing from
opposite directions.
I'm seeing it, right?
I'm letting the company do it's
thing but I'm a force that's
equal to the
company of magic, right?
And I'm pushing, now
start to really figure it out.
I'm kinda like almost
weirdly separating them.
I'm even thinking
things of like Gary tax, right?
And basically,
that's just offense, right?
That's Lindsay
saying hey I really see it,
I want to go for it.
And I'm like cool, Gary tax it.
And so what that would mean
is that she can still run the
business or her
division properly,
subtract the weird
things I did dollars-wise and
then see if she's
running an actual business.
I'm going to a secret meeting
and I'll see you guys later.
Because what was happening was
the leaders were all under Gary
tax and they didn't
know how to run a business.
Because my halo of being
able to create top line revenue
protected all their inabilities
and as we scale I want to give
them other opportunities
I needed them to be able
to be capable outside of magic.
Like that fuck face
back there, Michael Jordan,
he solved all of
BJ Armstrong's problems.
He made up for
Horace Grant's shortcomings.
When he wasn't there,
Bulls weren't good anymore.
And so, I need to make sure that
when I'm not coming over the top
and fixing everything with my
magic that they actually know
how to do something
so that my magic is
added value not
what keeps us alive.
Got it?
- Yeah, yeah. For sure.
- That's cool.
- Alright, there's one
thing that I have to...
- I've never talked
about that before.
Karma is practical.
I love how people think
karma is like this weird thing.
Doing good for other
people a good strategy.
You know, I've been trying.
I'm like why does
this thing even exist?
It's actually the most
common sense thing of all time.
Why does karma seem weird?
The fuck is karma?
Like wait a minute, so you're
telling me if you do lots of
good things that weirdly
good things happen to you.
Yeah, that seems
like common sense.
Heading out.
Big day tomorrow.
All good stuff.
See ya, DRock.
("Beautiful Day" by
Davon ft Eric Wortham II)
I always say if you
want to be an anomaly
you have to act like one.
People want all these special
things to happen but then
they're acting
like everybody else.
And that gets into the Saturdays
in your 20's or just like taking
risk or things of that nature.
I totally agree with you.
I think about it as, you know
that picture where it looks like
two people kissing or it
looks like a glass of champagne?
I just basically think at
this point in my business life,
the world sees the
glass of champagne and
I see the two people kissing.
("Beautiful Day" by
Davon ft Eric Wortham II)